hi there Steve Kaufman here to talk
about language learning and I want to
talk today about advances in language
surgery why language learning is
becoming easier and easier I have talked
in the past about some of the major
advances in language learning for
example mp3 technology I talked about 50
years ago when I would listen to an open
reel tape recorder in my room in Hong
Kong when I was learning Chinese
Mandarin Chinese
and now the iPhone that I'm filming this
on is also a major language learning
tool I use it to listen to I use it to
read on I use it to link on and of
course I have my handy-dandy iPod or DS
iPad here and I have my computer and
open on my computer and I've also got a
lesson here an Arabic lesson open my
iPad by the way it was a blog produced
by a person in Egypt talking about
historical figures in our big culture
al-biruni if I remember going over it I
did it somewhat ago so we are now
surrounded by this tremendous technology
and so far as you know audio files and
you know even little things like you
know these handy-dandy earphones and
normally I use my ear pods and and our
iPhones and you know Netflix for example
and and all these things contribute and
they contribute a lot of this stuff
contributes in a small way for example
I'm trying to do my standard Arabic my
wife happens to start watching this
eugenie night Egyptian movie on Netflix
so I kind of float through the room see
her watching it and of course at first I
don't want to watch it because there's
nothing ever happens but then after a
while it's kind of fun to see people
even if these are you know this is
fiction these are not real people this
is perhaps not what life really was like
but it is to
fun so these are real people speaking
Egyptian Arabic which I don't understand
but then I say all Netflix so then I go
to Netflix and I look up this movie and
lo and behold it has Arabic subtitles so
I can follow it and I now use this
learning languages with Netflix so I can
go you know frame by frame and it has
the dialogue in Standard Arabic sorry
it's fun to see them speaking stand
speaking in a way they're not speaking
Standard Arabic you're speaking Egyptian
Arabic but the words they are using if
they were speaking Standard Arabic this
is what they would be saying so with
that I say hey this is fun it brings the
Arabic alive to me so I contact our we
have a virtual assistant persons or an
whose tremendous he lives in Serbia and
I say he's alright can't we get someone
to rewrite the mini stories in Egyptian
Arabic and record them and then I could
get a handle on Egyptian Arabic so that
when I watch the movie with my wife I
can understand some of it so this is
kind of this sort of the impact of I
don't know Netflix modern technology
access to cultures around the world all
of which is stimulating my language
learning and there are many examples for
example you know I'll give you an
example here like I'm in my in my Farsi
here Persian so one thing I can do if I
go to this far go podcast which is one
of the ones that I'm using and I open up
a lesson and unfortunately we don't have
text-to-speech in Persian for whatever
reason I don't know why and we don't
have a lot of good content we have some
I've actually commissioned some people
to create content and that's there and
I've done it and so far they're always
not bad but one thing I didn't realize
our [ __ ]
I'm a co-founder of link I didn't even
know this existed if I click there
three little dots here on the upper
right-hand corner of the lesson page if
I click on it I get edit lesson so the
lesson here's where I can edit I can add
here's where I upload the audio and
there's a thing here called re split
text on the left hand side so I can
click on the Reese clip text it warns me
are you sure you want to Reese please I
say okay Reese clip and then there's a
thing called clips which I hadn't
noticed before
there's title and text there's resources
which could be a video it could be notes
translations but there's also clips say
open please and with that it says
generate audio timestamps so I kind of
generate audio timestamps and it does
its thing in the background for awhile
and once it's done lo and behold I now
can listen to this lesson if I and now
if I'm in sentence mode because again we
can either be in full text mode or
sentence mode I can actually listen to I
click on this audio here and the text
excuse me the audio it corresponds to
this section is going to be played now
in the case of the again we're talking
modern innovations in the case of these
podcasts I actually have to download the
audio file because I subscribe to the
podcast on iTunes I have to put that mp3
file in my
you know happy trans transcriber or
happy scribe or vocal Matic to convert
that into text that means there's no
punctuation that means that the
sentences are actually quite long so not
quite as good in Turkish I've done it
and where we use material that is not
automatically transcribed where we have
punctuation you actually get quite short
you know two three line sentences where
you the audio matches the text and it
makes it a lot easier now in languages
like Turkish and Arabic where we have
text-to-speech it's very nice it's not
crucial it's nice though because the
text-to-speech is often not accurate but
for a version where we don't have
text-to-speech this really really helps
and I didn't know about this so and I'm
sure there's lots of stuff at link that
I don't know about or the other users
don't know about but if you want to get
audio to match the text in sentence mode
do check out go to the Edit you know
using the three little dots here go to
edit make sure you Reese Plitt the text
and then automatic time stamps and
you're away so little things little
things you know that I guess help us
encourage us or make it easier and
they're coming at us all the time
there's continuing improvement in the
range of things that either stimulate us
help us allow us to access content and
content is key so I did an interview you
may have seen it with Johan who does
from Ceylon tea tremendous content he
just talked starts either it's a
monologue or he talks to people it's in
French it's just natural people talking
I wish someone would do that for Arabic
for Persian for Turkey Turkish we're
starting to get stuff from our members
or from other people who are posting
there but in all the languages rather
than creating text books what's needed
is massive amounts of this sort of
casual conversation content to bridge
the gap between the beginner content
like our mini stories
and then they margins and stuff like
these political podcasts so the worlds
of language learning is evolving step by
step little steps big steps and we all
benefit and that's what I wanted to talk
about today bye for now